so now we have modified our application
x 2 we can check that off and we have
one last thing to do we're going to add
a new feature now before we move on go
ahead and check in your changes if
you're using version control that way
you can start right here before you do
any of this stuff that's particularly
important because this challenge is
going to be a little bit more difficult
than the modification challenges our new
feature is going to be a priority button
so now there will be a little ! button
for each one of these elements when you
click on it the task will be highlighted
in red so you remember to prioritize it
over the others unless it's checked off
in which case it won't be read at all
now once again the CSS has been done for
you when you add the priority button
give it a class of priority dash BTN
when a task is marked as prioritized the
Li should get a class of priority now
just so you remember that I'm putting
that information down in the instructor
notes now once again I'll remind you to
be a detective first look around for
similar functionality and see where it's
implemented if you can and if you find
something you're curious about pull up
the documentation for backbone j/s or do
a google search to try and figure out
what's going on go ahead and implement
that priority button and good luck